[Music]
and the problem with social media is she
doesn't even have that lifestyle right
it's fake it's not even real like like
meaning she may not have the money for
it their marriage may be falling apart
like I want her life and if you saw the
whole 360 picture like a lot of people
putting the best foot forward know you
actually would not want to trade
[Music]
places woo this is John with the Dr John
delone Jo I'm so glad you were with us
on the greatest mental health and
marriage and emotional health and
parenting podcast that's ever existed
YouTube show however you're finding us
we're glad you are here on today's show
we have a very special guest my friend
New York Times bestselling author number
one bestselling author all over the
place YouTube sensation I don't know all
the nice things I could say about her
kind of kind of my boss actually she's
an owner of of the company where I
work the incomparable Miss Rachel Cruz
and Miss Rachel Cruz
um her and her husband are great friends
with me and my wife we hang out we do
Live Events all over the country
together we have conversations behind
closed doors about things like um
parenting what our what our kids are
experiencing being a mom being a dad
being a husband being a wife um and we
talk about comparison We compare
theological things it things just get
heavy so on this show we kind of go all
over the place and talk about some hard
heavy things some hard um discussions
about comparison about um being a mom
about Mom guilt all of it we have lots
to discuss we go all over the place and
I'm glad that you get to hear this
conversation so buckle up put your
headphones in turn up a little bit
louder you may want to slow it down a
little bit cuz I talk way too fast so
they say in the in the internet comments
please enjoy my conversation with with
one of my great friends Miss Rachel
Cruz thanks for coming yeah thanks for
having me you're like super in demand
you're real famous and you joined me on
not real that's not real it's for sure
real yes I've traveled with you all over
the country it's for sure real yeah man
people behind you like oh my gosh is
that Rachel Cruz and everyone's like
johnone yeah they don't do that they're
like hey is that Rachel Cruz all right
so a couple things I want to talk about
today probably have some conversations
that you haven't had on other shows that
was kind of my goal but more importantly
I like it when a podcast kind of drops
in on a conversation between two friends
that sounds like we just showed up while
they were having coffee and you and I
have done that all over the country and
so y um here's where I want to start so
you and I did this marriage event and
you and I've done it multiple times and
this time people came it was like a
weekend retreat Y and there was a bunch
of people there from all over the
country all different walks of life
engaged about to get divorced to we've
been married 34 years we're Millionaires
and we just want to see what's next for
us totally I think to a person everybody
walked away from that thing us included
like something magical happened there
and so that's rare in our world right we
we all the time and they're great of
course they're all awesome but but
there's always like you do a tour and
there's like this particular city was
just magic and I don't know you I don't
know why it was just an energy whatever
but this was so special and unique and
so I've spent so much time just while
I'm walking in the woods just trying to
figure out what was so rad about that
weekend and one of the things you and I
have talked about that I want to unpack
a little bit is
this one of the special gifts to the
audience is is that um or in that event
was I hide my wife you hide Winston over
time or really they hide from what we do
and so one of the cool things was they
showed up yes they came out on stage yes
and it was supposed to be like a fun
give for the audience and look at this
you get to finally meet them they're
real and she's beautiful and Winston's a
smoke show and like here's them MH when
I reflect back on it and you reread the
the feedback that was some of the most
powerful that was one of the most
powerful hours of the entire weekend yes
yes and as you and I have discussed I
think it comes from this place where
they could look at you and
Winston you are a co-owner of a multi
hundreds of million dollar company your
husband is extremely successful very
talented
you all both work really hard and you
all
have vast resources and then you look
over and there's me and Sheila and the
other two chairs and we have three phds
and two master's degrees between us and
I think there was a Humanity to you and
Winston
saying no marriage is real hard we're
having to figure this thing out where do
you think that illusion comes from so
that's a long setup to ask this question
where do you think this illusion comes
from that if we just had this everything
would be okay everything would be okay
and it could be money it could be all
the answers it could be all the training
it could be all the resour where does
that come
from I don't know I do feel
like specifically with us maybe and I
could be off based on this us or you and
Winston sorry us and our
jobs is cameras and microphones TVs
radio like there is a level of a
platform there and I do think with
anyone
maybe except for like Hollywood or
something but you you do look at people
on and I do this for people too I like
look at I look at them whether social
media or whatever and I just think oh my
gosh okay they they look happy for the
most part right like I know they're real
people but like like my struggle is like
woo 30% 40% of the time or whatever
theirs is they probably have some but
theirs is probably like 5% of the time
and whatever that game is that I play I
associate when I see people that I
admire or respect or have helped me
personally I think oh gosh they're doing
great I know they're human so I know
there's a percentage of them that
struggles but it can't be the same
percentage that I struggle and I think
it's that barrier of like putting
someone to a degree on a pedestal and
not that people do that with us all the
time not saying like we're on this big
pedestal platform but there has to be
something about this difference because
I don't feel that way with like my good
friends right but it's enough of a is it
because you know them yeah and I guess
you just see their Humanity more on a
daily basis and I just don't think we
have the opportunity to do that all the
time right like I think about for me I'm
like I have three you know quick
episodes a week I'm on the Rams like
like my time in front of people is so
limited and it's curated and it's
curated to a degree because I'm good as
we can look yeah and I and I try to be
human on it I try not to like put on a
complete fake face but I'm like but I'm
not going to pull up my phone in the
middle of a fight with Winston and be
like I just need you guys to see like
I'm like that's so inappropriate like I
would never I like that's so crazy so
there is something to me that I I will
put even me a percentage on people's
struggle and say but it surely it's less
than
mine I need to put a pin in that surely
it's less than mine because that'll be
an important conversation later on um
when we talk about comparison I don't
know that answers your question but
there's just something about that I
think it's a distance thing maybe it's a
resource thing
um I I think I I wonder if it's hard to
be in our own skin and it's just easy to
look and go I feel this way surely they
don't right and so how do I get from
here to there and the world if you just
scroll Instagram it's like well you have
to have money and you have to buy this
thing and you have to have this thing
and you have to have this thing and you
got to go get this information listen to
this podcast read this book and it's
almost I remember the audience
going and it was almost free mhm or not
maybe almost maybe was completely
freeing to go oh they don't have it all
figured out either y we're okay yes and
that means we can all keep figuring this
out right right and I do wonder the
dynamic of that on stage you have both
couples sitting there where usually like
the people I'm thinking in my head it's
the it's the person and I know they're
married but I don't I'm not in a
conversation with their spouse or I'm
not watching that conversation happen so
I think there's like two pieces of the
puzzle of like oh wow this is this is it
and I'll give kudos to our spouses we're
very honest yeah yeah yeah you me
they're very smart and they're yeah and
that vulnerability though too I think
gave that there wasn't this like oh gosh
we have to image
management level of like you and I did
not marry image managers no we were not
image managers that weekend which I
think is what brought some of the magic
to because yeah like so what makes
marriage so
hard like if you had to distill it down
I have an idea or two but and I'm not
even talking about the nerd literature
like what do you think it is I feel like
for when I feel like what I've learned
that I didn't realize and I feel like
I've been my eyes have been open more in
the last probably 24 months I think 2019
was a hard year for us and we started
doing some work and then we kind of like
ramped it up even in the last year or
two and I just don't think I realized
how much self- protection I brought into
marriage Define self- protection
protecting my myself protecting my ego
my feelings wanting to feel safe all of
it without knowing it that's what was
that's what's waked me out about
understanding myself is I'm like all
this is subconscious it's not like your
body's protecting you you don't even
know I'm like oh yeah and and and then
you're you know and then I'm sitting
down with my therapist and she'll say
something and she's like yeah well
that's that's little Rachel who is dying
for this and this and this and it's
coming out in a
35-year-old body and I was
like really is that what that is you
know I'm like I didn't even know that's
what I was doing and Winston the same
way and he would if he was sitting here
he would be very honest with that too
I'm like there was something again not
conscious it was subconscious of like I
just had to protect myself and that
comes out sideways and in different ways
and in our marriage it was caretaking it
was a level of codependence all of that
where again not knowing that was
happening and then you end up in this
like dysfunctional dance and then you
wake up and you're like wait this isn't
healthy cuz I I mean it's kind of
working like it's you know as one
therapist said I heard they were like it
works until it doesn't work right like
alcohol and cocaine they work great yeah
it's great like they kill you yeah
exactly so so yeah so I think part of
marriage that is hard is we just bring
in so much stuff you can say from
childhood or whatever and we we at the
core of us are trying we're trying to
protect ourselves always to a degree so
what have you found that you were trying
to protect what was your body trying to
keep safe
uh and here's why I as that question I
don't mean like deep dark secrets I'm
saying you have identified this other
person in marriage you were my ride or
die
y I'm all in and that's a CO like a
cognitive Choice I'm choosing you yes
yes your body goes oh no right and it
kicks up the defense 247 365 and it
plays out for a decade that way yeah
right until somebody at work laughs at
your joke
and suddenly your body goes oh we can
bring our defenses down CU she's safe or
he's safe or this thing happens or that
thing happens or the mailman knocked on
the door and he's really attractive like
oh my God the Christmas tree guy two
Christmases ago the Christmas tree guy
right whatever oh was he a smoke show
literally I walked I was all like
disheveled and I was like oh wow you're
actually a very good-looking Christmas
tree decorator guy are you yeah is this
like yeah he was selling like lights we
didn't even go with their company sorry
company but anyways but like
so
what what was your body protecting you
from
um I think a level of not wanting to be
hurt so I can live in this um it sounds
just like poana and it's not that it
doesn't feel that shallow I'm just
naturally the the glasses half full
naturally I'm always going to like yeah
and everything's going to be okay we're
going to figure it out and that mindset
that has been drilled in that I've found
make life better you know Rachel 15 at
in high school if you get left out of
something it's okay it's going to be
fine it's next it's fine don't worry
about that next week like like I would
always tell myself it's going to be okay
it's going to be okay so then when when
hard stuff in marriage happens something
that boils up that I actually needed to
be like what the is going on I was like
you know what it's going to be okay it's
going to be okay and because I'm like I
don't want to feel that pain I don't
want to feel that hurt I don't want to
feel pain hurt loneliness like all of
those I'm good it's going to be okay
because truthfully too through most of
like life it h it has like I got
friendliest SE with high school like I
like I was you know like for the most
part it has played out until it starts
to not and you start to see wow this
thing that brought me through that I
thought was actually helping I think in
the long term it it harms you because
there's parts of me that I think I did
shut off to protect to make it be okay
it's going to be okay and and the only
way to deep powerful marriage was going
through that stuff that's not okay
that's right and it was intense we had
an intense season yeah and yet it was
the healthiest breaking that needed to
happen for both of us and that's the
sick thing too is I'm like for Winston I
again he I'm not telling Secrets if he
was sitting here you'd say the same
thing where we both can lean in like
codependent or some people I think can
lean very independent and protect
themselves that way we almost found the
safety in each other to an unhealthy
degree which sounds funny in marriage
cuz in my head too in marriage no it's
all okay cuz you're married you have
this label of marriage over you so all
of this is fine right until you realize
oh my gosh individually I am not a
healthy person and Winston said this in
money of marriage on the panel but it's
true he was like you can't like if
you're both C+ people you can't have an
A+ marriage like that's a good like it
doesn't average out like that and so I
think for us too the protecting oh it's
going to be fine it's going to be
fine and couple that with a level of
codependence that like if you're good
I'm good like we're going to we're good
like life is good we're good we're good
we're good we're good like you live and
again it's not like once and I were
shallow people we had good conversations
we were connected we did therapy
together right like I mean during some
of this and like so when I that's that's
the other thing that that's the other
thing that kind of shocked my system is
I was like oh my gosh a plus b doesn't
always equal C my therapist said that to
me and I was like it's so true like you
can love Jesus you can do all the things
here you can both do self-work and to a
degree and all this here and somebody
leaves still something happens like and
that messed with me John oh because life
isn't an algorithm right yes and I
wouldn't have said life's an algorithm
if you asked Rachel three years ago is
life in I'm like no stuff happens all
the time right but not to me but
subconsciously I thought yeah but if
you're wise and and not that we're not
going to make unwise decisions and
expect right there there is a level of e
what you so to a degree but also some
years it just doesn't rain some years it
doesn't happen some years you plow the
field plan it perfectly and there's no
yes yes so it's all of that like and so
me and Sheila was detangling all was
opposite where
hers I very much had a she's going to
leave it any minute and hers is very
much independent hers was he's going to
leave it any minute but she solved that
by Independence and list and I Sol that
I solved it by trying to hang on and so
we had this like it was it was amazing
and then we'd go and this when the VIN
diagrams are across right well thanks
for thanks for talking about that I I
think there's this idea that yeah if you
just do all the right things marriage is
perfect right and if it's not perfect
then we need to scour the Earth for all
the right things my aim is different now
and it is I'm going to do all these
things that I know in this moment to be
right and by the way I've learned in the
last five years and before that I
learned different things and before that
I had different things and all of that
does is brings me to a baseline that
gives me a chance not that it guarantees
an outcome and I think there's something
powerful about that outcome not being
guaranteed because then I got to keep
showing up and then I got to keep
showing up and that keeps me from
getting complacent it keeps me from just
phoning it in it keeps me every day
looking at Sheila like this morning I
was like how can I love you today Y and
she's like just hug me right now and I
was looking for this like gesture and
she's like just let me just hold me for
a minute yep and off those lines because
you said that and I was like oh my gosh
it's so true because I think part of the
dynamic and the formula of that of just
keep showing up all of it is showing up
and continuing to push into the pain
because I think for so long I was like
oh my gosh if that's that bad thing
there or that that's wrong or that's
yeah we stay away from that we we attach
to something else we go we go where I
think I'm learning I'm like oh no it's
actually through through the pain
through the grossness through the
messiness that is actually life like
that's where it is we're so we a we
avoid it and we think you know and in
the Christian circles you could label it
sin you could label it suffering you can
like all right I think every every
person has their thing and for so long
it's like nope we avoid no where you're
actually like what is what is going on
in me that's causing that or wanting
that or whatever and it's actually
through that I got to like go through it
and not just say that's wrong oh we're
going to turn this way and White Knuckle
our way to be better just hold on to and
to run and to go it's actually like
facing it yeah and the beauty the
beautyy of marriage is you hold hands
with somebody you go let's go through
this together we're headed through I
think for so long it's like I could
identify the hard and like oh that's it
okay yeah let's work on that let's work
on that but I think it's even I think
it's even like two layers deeper where
it's like no no no we're going to like
go through
that and and and through it yeah I just
think I I think I just had this
avoidance of not just the hard like I
feel like that even sounds like oh it's
like the hard we can avoid that it's
almost like oh no that's that that
thing's not okay and that's wrong over
there so we're just going to turn our
backs and and and be good and and turn
that way versus being like huh that's
kind of messy right there let's actually
like sit in that talk about it go
through
it I'm always getting asked if there are
any new products that I've run across
that are changing the game for anxiety
worry focus and sleep and if you've
listened to this show I'm always telling
you that technology won't save us
because we don't need bioh hacks we need
to transform our nervous systems through
movement mindfulness nature and so forth
and while I still believe in critically
important lifestyle changes I have
discovered a new wearable that is
literally changing my life and my
family's life I'm wearing it around my
ankle right now and if I didn't know
that it was the result of brilliant
neuroscientists and Technology experts
working together I would think this
device came straight out of Hogwarts
It's Magic I'm talking about aollo or
also known as the Apollo wearable you
can wear it on your wrist like I said
I'm wearing mine on my ankle you can
just clip it to your shirt and it
actively improves your health by
transforming and strengthening your
nervous system it doesn't just measure
your health and fitness it changes you
for the better Apollo delivers gentle
pulse vibrations that feel like your
body is experiencing the Rhythm and
beats of different songs these higher
vibrations help improve energy and focus
while lowering vibrations reduce stress
and help you relax since day one I've
experienced less stress more energy
relaxation and focus and get this my rim
sleep improved more than 90% from one
night to the next I know since wearing
Apollo I'm a better husband a better dad
and I can show up better for all of you
and my kids are getting in on the Apollo
too you cannot improve your marriage
your relationship to your kids or how
you show up in your community if you're
not sleeping if you're riddled with
anxiety and if you're not able to focus
along with making changes about how you
choose a non-anxious life the Apollo
wearable is a GameChanger that can
accelerate your healing Journey go to
apollon neo.com
backone or go to apollon neo.com and use
promo code delone at checkout for 15%
off your purchase it's changing my life
and it can change
yours so um I'm going to read a couple
of things about you okay that I got off
the internet oh Lord just kidding I mean
tweets no that would be super fun tweets
you're a multi-time bestselling author
you're an ays and a co-owner of a $300
million company I like saying ER that
sounded fun you had a very successful
Show podcast YouTube show whatever um
you've got very successful product lines
like things with your name stamped on
them right and you got three amazing
kids and like my kids play your like
they're great kids and an amazing
husband so I've watched you as my friend
push back on this lie that as a
successful working woman
slom you can have it all do it all all
the same time like there's this mom
guilt thing and there's this mom guilt
Factory y y and so so many of my callers
are in that cycle and they're on
different places
right how do you and again going back to
we talking about earlier with marriage
like there just illusion like if I just
had this then right right how do you
experience mom Guild like when you're
not with your kids you're on a shoot
somewhere or you and I are doing a live
event in Minnesota yeah part of your
body's like I should be with them Y and
then when I'm with them part of you is
like I'm intentionally sacrificing my
career right now because I could be
doing these interviews I could be in New
York I could be in La doing this thing
how do you balance that because it's a
tornado right
yep um I think
I have and I know not everyone has
this um you'd say opportunity ability so
I I recognize that as I say this out
loud I think the season my kids have
been in I have tried to follow meaning
when they were younger babies and all
that and I'm sure people are like no you
need the attachment all this there was a
level me that I didn't feel as B like I
was like I didn't work crazy hours I
pulled back some but I like was with
them enough all of it and then when they
started hitting this Like Preschool to
Early Elementary School Days my mom like
radar just spiked and it was when I was
pregnant with Charles and it went out
the roof and I was like oh I need to be
I need to I I I want I don't need I
really want to be home more like
whatever I don't know if it was stage of
Life of kids I'm missing the bu yeah yes
the busyness I realized oh my gosh I
find my desire is Shifting cuz my desire
was always working mom and it was great
and I mean I went back early from
maternity leave with my first with a
million I went back like two weeks early
cuz I was like she's great we had we got
a great girl that was watching her and I
felt great I was like I'll go in for a
few hours like I just was like it really
didn't like shake me to my core I mean I
was sad at certain points for sure but
um but when I was pregnant with Charles
I felt this like like I can't do I can't
keep the schedule because at the time
this is before covid and all that we
were traveling was it kids or was it
work no it was more kids okay I felt
that so you you were more like I'm going
to sacrifice this thing I love and I've
worked for 15 years for to be home more
yes yes I did I felt that shift but then
what's funny is 6 months later after
Charles was born Co hits and our work
where most people's work died down some
people lost jobs ours spiked out the
Wazoo and every interview I ever wanted
was Suddenly at my doorstep and it's
like this show wants you and this show
wants you can you come in come in so
then I found myself two weeks in working
more than I had worked even like even
before that the amount of hours
that I was spending and then I did start
to feel this like resentment towards
work cuz I'm like I'm supposed to be
home more like I deliberately took a
season to be home more and here I am
working more than ever like this is
opposite of what I was expecting so yes
I did think like if people would just do
a budget I wouldn't have to come in and
like tell people to be on a bunch you
know like I had some of those thoughts
but that died down pretty quick um but I
took a season I mean really the last I
mean three years or so I have I haven't
I've I've kept the show I've kept things
going
work-wise um but I've been home more and
it's felt great I have tried to follow
the seasons of my kids and now Charles
is in school three days a week so what
I'm here on a Wednesday like I'm like oh
yeah I'll come in and do stuff like like
my I have opened my schedule more but
I've kind of followed my kids schedule
for that does that make sense absolutely
so yeah I don't know if all that well
and and I'm just thinking to the um and
you mentioned this earlier as a caveat
I'm thinking of the mom that can't
afford to do that just can't or is like
whose husband won allow it or
whatever I
think I don't think guilt is the enemy I
think it's something to feel and
acknowledge and then we go like we
talked about earli I think you go
through it I think you do the best you
can with what you have and you
acknowledge yeah in an ideal perfect
world this would be the world right and
the world's not ideal or perfect so
what's the best worldle we can create
with the record that's playing right
what world can we create there y yep and
that may mean that I only get two hours
a night with my kid kids after I get off
work and get them picked up we don't
have screens in this house because those
two hours are magic golden time yep and
do I Collapse every night at 8:15 yep
that's the world we got right now and
you said it best it's a season because
in a few years they're all going to be
in school or a few years they're going
ones be Middle School one's going y it
goes so fast and I think too
um like I have found with my kids cuz
when I didn't pull back and I was
working more with the two girls I'm like
they're going to be okay yes kids are so
res
and I heard this thing John and it just
rubbed me the wrong way and I don't know
if it's true so I'd be curious from like
a psychological standpoint and I can't
even remember who it was it was cuz it
made me feel bad as a mom working when I
heard this the mom guilt e system yeah
and it was like when you feel guilt
leaving your kids it's your body telling
you you're supposed to be with them
you're supposed to be with them so be
with them like it was this whole like it
was kind of a mom's don't work message
and I was like I don't like it I don't
like it but then I'm like oh my God what
if that's true what if that's true like
what do you
is that true or is it that we're guilt
because of soci like well I think I
think there's a difference between
supposed supposed to yeah in this Ideal
World um I tell people who have to bury
their kids it's not supposed to be this
way your kids are supposed to bury you
that's the way this is supposed to work
you're not supposed to and yet here we
are right this is the world that we got
dropped into and so I think they're
right but you shouldn't weaponize that
that's good so I think yeah whenever I
leave like after I've been on the road
for a season and then somebody calls and
says hey I drew elk tags let's go elk
hunting and I'm like
sweet I get on a plane and my body's
like you've been on the road you should
be at home mhm you're right like that
that feeling is correct yes and I'm
going to choose to show my kids that Dad
goes and provides dad goes and has fun
with his dad's got to
so I'm going to Pi this one it's
supposed to but I'm a single mom and I
have to work what do you do so in an
Ideal World this would be the way this
is yes and I would say the gift you give
to people
is um and this is something I've taken
infinitely more seriously before I
started here and you give moms a picture
of a different way it could look like
because so many and and I do too I I
hear so often okay my dad didn't show up
my mom was all over the place I want it
to be different but it's like trying to
explain what basketball is and then they
walk out on a court they've never seen a
game played they've never seen a ball
dribbled yep and then you expect them
just go play yeah that's hard you got
two little kids and school and work I
think the influencer thing can sometimes
get a bad rap I think it's a problem no
but I think can get a bad rap if
it's used to I'm going to show you a
picture of in your head you probably
think Rachel Cruz is out in Paris right
now this is me with my kids on a
Saturday with a sidewalk chalk this is
what this looks like and you give moms
permission to go oh God I thought I was
failing them by throwing pine cones at
each other and it's like no per this is
what it is right this is what it is yes
yes and so um anyway I I I just I love
the conversation it is so hard and I
feel it for moms and and again that's
one that's one of the and I use this
example a lot even in my show with my
content with money wise because I do
talk to moms that are like oh my gosh I
um you know I want to be free from all
this financial like obligation with debt
that we have because if I did I would
probably choose something different
right and so like that's that's an
example we use a lot with moms and
families is like you know especially a
um a nuclear family it's like yeah that
that is a that could be a motivation to
get out of debt and then you talk to
some moms that are like oh yeah
regardless of my options I still choose
this work because I love it and right
and that would be me like I mean I'm
like I genuinely enjoy my job and I love
it and it gives me an out it gives me
something else and so that's healthy too
right so I'm like you can hold both well
it's I think of myom a personal thing
who was a state on Mom and I got such a
gift from that or she worked part-time
yeah yeah yeah then I part of my life
was the mom who went back to college and
became this Guru at Deo in Tu and then
became this professor that travels the
world and that was a huge benefit right
right and so it's both hands that's
right that's right yeah um but it's hard
it's hard for anyone I know hard and so
maybe the meta lesson here is if it's
hard and you feel like something's wonky
yes mhm yep like it's not trying to
solve for this is hard right it's trying
to solve for okay this is hard what are
we going to do with that right how we
going to navigate this but it not being
hard isn't an optional y that's right
that's right it's
good hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow hallow is the number one Prayer
app in the world on planet Earth and
they're giving you three free months to
get started and people always say you
got to meditate you got to pray you got
to have a spiritual life and for many of
us we don't even know what that means we
don't even know where to start that's
where hallow steps in three free months
to prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the lowii station that I love
guided prayers meditations and more and
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hall makes it easy
to practice mindfulness build a deeper
more meaningful spiritual life to figure
out what you even believe in the first
place and choose peace and remember Hall
is giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone toay and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90-day trial that's hall.com
delone I want to talk about something
you talk about a lot okay and I want to
come up with a new framework and this is
going to get kind of nerdy and that's
okay okay good cool it's okay yes all
right I want to talk about comparison
okay and here's where I want to kind of
unpack it and so I'm going to talk too
much but you're the comparison Guru and
I've been trying to like dig into the
nerd stuff of comparison
yes and here's what I've come up with
and so I want by the time we get done
going back and forth I want to land on a
new framework about comparison okay okay
so we have Teddy Roosevelt Mark Twain Dr
Cummings whoever you say it comparison's
the thief of Joy the of Joy all
that so I've written this down so if
you're watching this on YouTube I'm
reading some of this I just want to make
sure I get this right there's a lot of
scientific literature tons about how
comparison social comparison is the nerd
word is actually wired into US
comparison is a feature of being an
animal not a problem not a bug MH we
have such an innate need for connection
that we're designed to always be looking
for where we stand Rank and compare
always be doing this all the time
because if our tribe leaves us we're
dead right so wired into US is this idea
of am I over here am I over here where
do I stand I'm short I'm tall I'm big
I'm strong what's my role what am I
supposed to be doing so I started to ask
myself if comparison is part of us wired
into us as a feature not a bug in the
system I also look around and comparison
is a thief of Joy it destroys us right
and so I'm trying to navigate both of
them it's an an innate part of us yeah
and in this current world we live in it
kills us it destroys our marriages it
destroys everything right and
so you've talked to moms for years
you've talked to many and women for
years you've been having this
conversation about comparison comparison
comparison if I tell you if I lay both
of those down that it's a part of us
it's it's how we're wired it's how we're
built and designed and yet it kills us
how does that hit you does that hit you
as right or does that hit you as because
think where we get off because I think
comparison is the V I think it's the
thing that we it's the it's the car we
jump in to ride but when we start to
turn on the jealousy routes and the Envy
rout I wrote in down yeah down so that's
that's that's the actual thing that I
think destroys us I think comparison is
the thing we get in that leads us there
but like yeah comparing you know um two
you know my sweater and her sweater it's
like oh mine's cable knit hers is okay
okay yeah yeah that's cool that's cool
that's great I I made a comp comparison
a literal comparison but then suddenly
when I want what she has and I don't
have it so now I want to get it that's
envy and jealousy and that's the world
that I think takes over that bad that's
the problem I think so comparison in and
of itself may not be the demon it's Envy
I think so because you can't have Envy
without comparison right I think a start
a starting line is comparison right
right right yeah I don't think you just
jump
to um you
oh I want that there's a level of like
oh my gosh well especially when it's a
person right because you're comparing
with another person another human being
they have something and I want it
whether it's the marriage the lifestyle
the whatever like and again I think
there can be a oh I want that and I'm
still good with myself and content and
maybe that's something I strive for
that's a fun job I would love to do that
one day right like there's like that's
not that's not jealousy all right the
last one is and you wrote an amazing
book about it let me grab it an amazing
book sweet little book look at that
sweet book so my wife is a children's
literature efficient a right and her I I
don't fully understand how smart she is
but I know that she taught teachers how
to teach kids how to read She's Like A
literacy person and she's a huge
proponent of children's literature and
how pictures are reading and turning the
pages is actually technology and it's
it's a it's a path for kids neural
connections to begin to to to develop
right so you can read a book like
this and you can read a book like this
when you're a a young one right and
there's some really clear scientific
literature that says you want to set
your kids apart over an arc of their
life read to them when they're young so
when you said hey I'm putting out
children's book I was super excited
about it and then of course this is just
so magical and beautiful a lot of this
it's called I'm glad for what I have but
you talk about what I think is the
antidote for Envy the antidote for all
of this is gratitude being grateful what
you got y right and not not being
ambitious not having dreams for the
future but being able to stay right now
in contentment I'm so blessed cont so
tell talk about cont there's like a
sense of just peace that we're okay like
we can have nice stuff we don't have to
have nice stuff like regardless of
what's going on around us there's just
this level of where we are settled we're
going to find happiness and joy and that
it's kind of what we're talking about
earlier but that's I mean for me that's
what it is it's a choice yeah and the
stuff may come and go but regardless of
that is beyond it's beyond that is how
are you feeling what's your state of
your heart like where are you at so
would you agree that that's something
you
practice yes oh I think so like a skill
and gratitude I think is part of that
right I think being grateful for what
you have leads into that contentment um
but it's a Cho I'm like but there's a
level of like I have to I have to choose
this and sometimes it comes easier than
others and I feel like that's the fun
part when it does become like oh no okay
we're good like they're they're over
here doing this XY or the new Suburban
pulls in but I got my minivan I'm good
I'm good you can go over there and be
like this car is amazing yeah be excited
for people oh sure and that doesn't mean
you hate your car no and you can go home
and be like I want to have that Suburban
one day cool let's put the work in let's
figure out what that would look like
right yeah y our marriage isn't going to
change if we have that Suburban just so
we know right right right um it's good
but yeah so the kid book I was excited
about it because I have yeah four six
and 8-year-old at home and K yeah like
bedtime stories it's a thing and I
always love the books that have like a a
message at the end that I'm like as a
parent I'm like oh that was so good to
hear so I wanted that I wanted it to be
short I wanted it to rhyme I wanted to
have am so I had this like whole dream
and contentment yeah is um for me a huge
message for my kids cuz I'm a natural
spender I'm the one that can be the like
oh my gosh I'm going to accumulate cuz
it's fun and I love it um and my kids
started to be like where's the Amazon
guy like you know like they started
asking questions I was like oh no oh no
I've turned them into to me so I wanted
a book just to walk them through the
story of like hey you want new toys you
want all of this stuff and it's not
right or wrong right there's not like a
moral compass to this stuff but at the
end of the day can we understand that
the stuff is not the thing that's going
to fulfill us and so that was yeah that
was the message I wanted to to put in
and um yeah and there's a spiritual
element at the ends of God and we've
talked about this but having a higher
power choosing to look Beyond yourself
and attaching yourself to something else
besides just you is really healthy so
for me it's God and it's in the book but
for other people maybe something else
which is fine but that's another big
thing that I'm like when we become our
own Gods like that's when it life gets
messy I think you've talked about this a
lot which I think is so I think it was
used when I was hearing it I was like
that is so right that's it like that's
that's so right I like to think of it
like when the more I stare at my own
belly button I can only go in a spiral I
can only go in a in a quick spinning
spiral y it's when I pick my head up and
beyond that picking my head up I also I
mean my my hands are coming up right now
if you're if you're not watching this
but it's this sense
of I don't control anything I don't
control anything and I'm going to be
grateful for where I got put and because
I happen to live in this little sliver
of History I have an opportunity to
maybe earn some more money or maybe um I
can do some neat things professionally
or whatever but I'm going be grateful
for what I get
and yes comparison is wired to me I'm
going to look to my right and my left
and make sure I'm treating my wife right
make sure I'm my kids are healthy and
somewhat developmentally
appropriate but I'm also not going to
just walk around envious of I wish I had
that and I can't believe they have that
they don't deserve that I'm not going to
live like that I'm going to choose to
open my hands up and look up and say
thank you and right please give me a uh
give me some rain tomorrow yes right yep
yep and it just my whole body just even
saying that a lot my body just goes
right it's like restful
yes totally cool well thanks for coming
to hang out I know thanks for having me
on appreciate it and for those of you
watching this conversation we just have
all the time it's just youall get to
hear it so cool I know so appreciate you
you're awesome
cheers hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right we are back thanks for hanging
out and listening to my conversation
with Miss Rachel Cruz all of her books
and show info and everything will be in
the comment section I mean will be where
will be down below in the whatevers yeah
it'll be below in the thing L linked in
a place at the thing where we can get
all of her stuff and whatnots and Jenna
I should have pointed out that you cheat
on me with her show too uh you know
actually I was with her first oh so I'm
I'm the other guy woman yeah I'm the
other woman yes excellent excellent all
right Kelly so we're gonna wrap up
today's show with uh am I the
problem let's do
this all right and first all before we
start people we need your in my the
problem emails so please send those um
to ask at johal.com is that
right John johal.com
ask there you go not to the email
address go there put am I the problem
like in the first line you guys can see
what a great producer I'm working with
she even know where we are they know
what I have to deal with here we go they
know all right so send in your emails
please keep them short but we need some
more all right this is from Lynn in
Mission TCH
am I the problem my husband
procrastinates when doing yard work
cleaning up up after himself repairing
things or cleaning areas of the house
his workbench in the garage Etc that he
says are that he says are his
responsibility I don't like to neag so
instead of asking him repeatedly
sometimes I just go and do it myself
especially when the backyard gets very
overgrown like 2 feet or more but then
when he comes home and sees that I did
it he gets really mad I feel like he
wants to do it on his time or in his
terms or he's not happy am I the problem
no he is the problem you are seeing a
need and you are then waiting longer
because your husband has a fantasy that
he's fulfilling in his mind and that's
he's the guy that takes care of the
house he is not he's the guy that talks
about taking care of the house and that
never does it and so you have to Wade
through a twot tall Texas backyard I've
had to do that it's the worst you are
not the problem you are solving the
problem that your husband is creating if
he gets mad it's because you've exposed
his his fantasy land so no keep it up
keep doing what you got to do because
nobody else is doing it somebody's
talking about it a lot but they're not
doing anything you are not the problem
what do you think Kelly yeah 100% my
husband he'll do that I mean it's always
like it's never intentional it's always
like I'm going to do that thing and then
things just happen and then I'll go by
and do it and but he never handles it
poorly he's always like man I know that
took me forever I'm so glad you took
care of it sorry about that you know or
you know like in our case what we did
was he didn't have time the lawn we were
having a problem so we hired somebody
yeah because it was worth the bit of
money to have the sanity back and not
and to take the problem out of the
marriage that's right and so he could
devotee time to hey I'd really rather be
doing these other house projects or
whatever great so we'll hire somebody so
I think the problem here is is that your
husband is Express is is using his shame
as a weapon on you he's embarrassed he
wants to be the guy that does the yard
he doesn't have the courage to say hey I
need to I need to offload this we need
to hire somebody or yall are in a
financial position we can't afford to
hire somebody cool um now if he's
working three or four jobs and he's just
just crushing it and but he also wants
to be the guy that does this too cool
you'all need to have like a come to
Jesus conversation a truth-telling
conversation you are doing so much for
our family that I'm going to take this
from you the problem is he's not having
that honest conversation for whatever
reason so yes you're doing a great job
you're not the problem he needs to get
with the
program good yep 100% agree all right
hey everybody thanks for joining us come
back and see us next time on the Dr John
deloney show don't do drugs
[Music]
bye